the American occult really became
established in the firmament of this
country probably between the 1690s and
the late 1840s and there were several
very definite personalities and groups
and events that made that possible as I
mentioned earlier by the 1680s 1690s
mystical groups began to flee Central
Europe and come to America if you flash
forward to 1776 you not only have the
shakers organizing their first village
outside of Albany New York but in the
state of Rhode Island there was a young
woman named Jemima Wilkinson who had
been caught up in the Baptist revival
that we call the Great Awakening and in
fall of 1776 Jemima who had grown up on
a prosperous Quaker farm took to her bed
with a terrible fever and she was
slipping in and out of a coma and her
family was sure that she was going to
die and then one day without any
antecedent whatsoever she leaped up from
the bed all red and ruddy and filled
with this renewed energy and announced
to her shocked Quaker family that she
would no longer be known as Jemima that
woman had died and that the being
standing before them would be known as
the public Universal friend and she
became in a certain sense the nation's
first spirit channeler by the early
1800s that area of central New York
State became known as the burned over
district it was a place that was
considered burned over with the fires of
religious passion and that's where you
start to see the first alternative
religious culture developing in America
and and really in the modern world the
Iroquois Indians had occupied central
New York State but they were pushed off
that land by the colonial government
just after the War of Independence so
central New York was opened to land
settlement and speculation and a whole
wave of relatively liberal New
Englanders began to flood into central
New York State and for about a
generation or two in the early to mid
1800s the place produced most of the new
religions that grew out of America
Mormonism seventh-day Adventism it's
where the shakers spread you had the
first experiments large experiments in
American utopianism the Oneida community
was located there the place was a hotbed
of political reform
the first women's rights conference was
held in Seneca Falls New York it was
also the birthplace of a movement that
we call spiritualism which involves
Sansa's and spirit wraps and talking to
the dead and spiritualism just became
the driving engine behind everything
because as spiritualism grew in central
New York State and it started
essentially in a little village called
Hyde's Ville outside the city of
Rochester where two teenage girls in
1848 told their Methodist household that
the bangs and raps and noises that were
being heard in their cabin were actually
spirit raps and the girls said we can
reach to the beyond and people believe
them they were hungry to believe them
because Americans saw themselves as a
people who were entitled to a kind of
new dispensation from God they used to
refer to the country sometimes as the
new Israel or the American Israel they
were they were expressing the most
radical impulses of the Reformation in
which people believed that you could
reach the beyond you could reach the
divine with no intermediary you didn't
need the man in robes you could do it
yourself and as soon as people began to
organize into seance circles and people
began to identify themselves as trance
mediums who could reach the beyond it
opened up a door for women to assume
their first roles of religious
leadership in the modern world this
really can't be overstated women had no
clerical role anywhere in the Western
world period when spiritualism dawned
suddenly women who wanted to engage in
the civic and religious and political
culture were becoming trance mediums it
is no accident that in this burned-over
district of upstate New York
you had the birth of spiritualism
coinciding with the first conference for
women's voting rights the two were were
branches coming out of the same tree for
about a generation in the 19th century
you could not find a voting rights
activist a suffragist activist who
hadn't spent some time at the seance
table and vice versa
the movements just absolutely grew out
of one another once that social and
spiritual opening was created for women
in the form of spiritualism sudden
ambitious women who wanted to
participate in the culture had a kind of
a voice so this began a marriage between
a cult spirituality and reformist or
radical politics that just roared
through the country and really has never
gone away so the 1840s some historians
call that decade the mad 40s the 1840s
was the pivotal moment in American life
where an avant-garde spiritual culture
began to grow and where a radical and
reformist political culture began to
grow
this was also bound up with ideologies
that were coming over to America from
Europe chief among them was the method
called mesmerism which we today call
hypnotism Americans were in love with
mesmerism because it was something that
you could do in your own home you could
you could mesmerized or hypnotized your
your your aunt or your mother or your
father and people would go into these
trance States and you could introduce
Auto suggestions to them whereas some
people saw it you could chore them of
illnesses and sometimes people would
emerge would re-emerge from a trance
state and report that they had some kind
of out-of-body experience they had
traveled to other realms or to other
planets or to the heavens call 2d
ologies all these supernatural
ideologies where people said they were
in touch with the world beyond they
could see either into other realms or
into the future or they could serve as a
spirit channel they were confirming a
very very deep-seated hope that
Americans had about themselves and they
served as a conduit for radical
radically liberal religious and
political ideas
you